95% of Who We Are by the age of 35 is
programmed is that true I think if we
Define a habit is a redundant set of
automatic unconscious thoughts behaviors
and emotions that's acquired through
repetition The Habit is when you've done
something so many times that your body
now knows how to do it better than your
conscious mind then it's programmed
subconsciously so then when the body
knows how to do it better than the
conscious mind then for the most part
the greatest habit we have to break is
the habit of being ourselves right so
there's a principle Neuroscience that
says that nerve cells that fire together
wire together if you keep thinking the
same way uh if you keep making the same
choices if you keep doing the same
things if you keep reproducing the same
experiences and feeling the same
emotions your biology begins to become
hardwired in a sense it becomes
programmed hey s Carmichael and I make
these videos because I need them from me
because I want to wake up every day and
watch a video that puts me in a mindset
to believe in myself more and go off off
and accomplish amazing things and attack
the day and I hope that this video does
that for you as well so today let's
learn how to attract things from the
universe with Dr Joe despenza
enjoy in order to change uh something to
arrive at a new vision of your future if
you were wanted to arrive at a new goal
or New Vision of your future you'd have
to change something about yourself in
order to get there and you'd have to
change the way you think the way you act
and the way you feel when you begin to
become
conscious of those unconscious thoughts
so conscious that you don't let them
slip by your awareness unnoticed or
unchecked by you if you catch yourself
speaking in a limited way or um you you
become conscious that you're behaving in
a certain way in a
habit and you can notice or pay
attention to how you're feeling then
you're no longer the program now your
Consciousness observing the program
you're only UNC conscious when you're in
the program and so to change then is to
become so conscious that you don't don't
go unconscious again and in a sense that
is consciousness that is really the
puppet master that really decides who we
want to be I think the biggest problem
uh is that people lose their free will
uh to a set of programs and so their
body is basically um programmed into a
predictable future based on what they've
done in the past so to change then to
change that habituation takes an
enormous amount of energy an enormous
amount of awareness rule number two is
create your personal reality if you're
truly in the business of change or
creating your life that's a big
responsibility right I mean like we we
we ran our event I said to the audience
okay nobody nobody forced you to come
here right you came here on your own you
took the risk in coming here by by
coming here you also agree that you
create your reality that you're
responsible for yourself and your life
so if something happens to you you can't
blame anybody because of that it's your
responsibility to take care of you right
so then the fundamental question is and
I ask myself this all the time at what
point do I stop
believing that I create my life at what
point when things go bad then all of a
sudden it's I didn't create
that that person is doing it to me right
so if we can if we can wire that in our
brains right that our reaction and
response to an environmental condition
is causing us to go back to the past
that's what the emotion is the familiar
emotion is the
past and I'm on the journey and I catch
myself doing that if I'm truly in the
practice every day and I can cultivate a
feeling not not not on the spot then
that you you you're not prepared your
meditation is the preparation of mind
and body for this so I don't get up from
my meditation until I'm in love with
life I don't I don't create anything
that's going to be unlimited until I
feel unlimited and in that space and if
I'm practicing feeling unlimited every
day I'm practicing
connecting to the emotions of my future
I'm I'm out of the bleachers and I'm on
the field if you're in the bleachers and
you're trying to not react to people in
in circumstances you don't have the
practice or the skill set on how to
create that emotion because you haven't
been practicing creating it and why do
we close our eyes and do it because the
environment is so seductive why do we
sit still and not move because you're
going to want to get up and pee and eat
and have a cup of coffee and feel so so
now you're telling your body hey stay
I'm going to feed you yeah you're going
to take a shower you're going to get
coffee you can play with your c phone
you can text you can talk trash you can
do anything you want but right now
you're not the mind I'm the mind and
you're going to sit and stay till I'm
done and when I condition you to the
emotions of the future and I get a very
clear image of who I'm going to be this
day and I'm not going to get up until I
feel that
way I guarantee you you're going to come
up against all those unconscious
thoughts they're going to come up right
there I I want people to I want them to
see it I want them to become so familiar
with it so conscious if they wouldn't go
unconscious they wouldn't let that
thought I can't ever slip by their
awareness unchecked they've done the
work in the beginning of the day they
suppress those circuits in the brain and
nerve cells that no longer fire together
no longer wire together you're you're
breaking down the old personality and so
you say ah you body wants to get up I
got to pee I want to have a couple I
want to check and you you watch your
body want to get up and you go hey hey
hey hey hey hey get over here you you
get back into this present moment and
you every time you do that it's a
victory you're executing a will that's
greater than an unconscious program and
most people lose their free will to a
program because they do the same thing
today as they did yesterday their body's
on autopilot and it's dragging them into
the same future habitually based on what
they did in the past so now you're
sitting there and it's just a little
uncomfortable and you want to quit and
your body you go no you get over here
and you bring it back now some people
say I can't meditate but really they're
actually doing it right that's a victory
too yeah and then you do that and you
start watching how you're training your
body back into the present moment then
it's your body says well you know Louis
it's uh this it's 8 8:30 in the morning
this is usually when you watch the news
and throw a tiate and get angry and I'm
and you're sitting here with your eyes
closed and you're off schedule so why
don't we just get agitated about
anything so the body starts trying to
create images in your mind so you
remember your ex you remember your
problems so you could feel that
agitation what if you watched your body
do that and you
said no no no no no I'm not going to
give my power away to the past or that
person or that circumstance in my life
you get that body back in the present
moment you lower the volume to that
emotion that's a victory you're telling
the body it's no longer the mind that
you're the mind now that kind of work is
tedious in the beginning but I watch
people because when I have them do that
it starts stretching their boundaries
the known self that little box starts to
move into the unknown and they survive
and all of a sudden they're more relaxed
in the present moment the unknown and
they start feeling more satisfied so now
they're more ready to create so the
preparation for the day is to remind
yourself of who you no longer want to be
to know thyself to become so familiar
with the word meditation means to become
familiar with so conscious of your
unconscious programs you're not going to
go unconscious why because you did you
did battle today with that personality
that's creating the same personal
reality and if your personality is made
up of how you think how you act and how
you feel and you want to create a new
personal reality then you got to change
your personality and that's going to
mean then you're going to become so
conscious of those unconscious programs
that you're no longer the program you're
the Consciousness observing the program
disentangling from that is not easy
that's why most people won't do it
that's why they get on their cell phone
and say let me just create a dopamine by
just seeing if I got a text from
somebody I like know your phone's over
there and you're no longer regulating
with something outside of you this is
this is game time so then if you
said what thoughts do I want to fire and
wire in my brain H with my attention and
my intention rule number three is be
present people can create all kinds of
wealth and they can create all kinds of
abundance they can have the cars the
homes and everything but if they can't
be present right to enjoy them I sat
with billionaires and they've looked me
in the eye and said we're all miserable
here we're all
miserable and and and and and so then at
what point do you have to wait uh to
change does it have to be that lowest
point or or or can you learn and change
in a state of joy and inspiration
instead of instead of pain and suffering
and that that becomes the art right so
then to change then is is to be greater
than the habituations the drives and the
emotions that have been conditioned in
the body to change is to be greater than
the conditions in our environment that
every person every object everything in
our life has a neurological Network
associated with them they're known
because we've experienced them and we
have an emotion associate with them so
you if you're not being defined by a
vision of the future you're left with
the memories of the past and you see
your ex and you're going to see your ex
through the memory of your past
neurologically and it's going to elicit
an emotional response and you're
thinking and feeling equal to your
environment your life's not going to
change so then the next question is how
could I
overcome that condition that with my ex
can I actually forgive could I actually
open my heart can I actually the reason
we do this is because the stronger the
emotion we feel towards someone or
something in our life the more we pay
attention to them and where we place our
attention is where we place our energy
and so then we're giving our power away
to that person or circumstance that's
vital life force you could use to change
the person who's sitting in the
meditation and they want to quit this is
they're thinking they're doing their
meditation wrong I want to tell you
you're doing it right that's the
defining moment right and you lower the
volume to that emotion I guarantee
you'll take your attention off that
person and sooner or later when the body
finally settles down and you get Beyond
it you're going to take your power back
and that's building your own
electromagnetic field now you have
energy to heal now you have energy toate
we measured this now you have energy for
for creation right let's demystify the
present moment okay people wake up in
the morning and they they think about
their problems and those problems are
memories that are etched in their brain
that are connected to certain people and
objects at certain times and places the
moment they wake up in the morning and
they start thinking of their problems or
thinking in the
past okay now every one of those
problems has an emotion associated with
it so when they feel unhappy when they
feel bitter when they feel fearful now
they're bodies in the past thoughts are
the language of the brain feelings are
the language of the body thought and a
feeling image and emotion stimulus and
response you're conditioning the body to
be the mind of that emotion
subconsciously now the body is believing
it's living in the same past experience
24 hours a day 7 days a week 365 days a
year why because the body is so
objective it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion and the emotion
that person is creating by thought alone
so important the body doesn't know the
difference and so what would the
environment signals the gene that's
epigenetics the end product from an
experience in the environment is an
emotion the person's signaling the same
genes in the same way and genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and function of your
body and the expression of proteins is
the expression of life and now the
person is actually headed for a genetic
Destiny and when people
labor for the present moment and they
take their attention off of their body
off of all the people in their life all
of the objects they own their cell phone
their computer their car their house
they're no longer identifying with where
they're sitting where they need to be
where they live where they've lived in
the past where they need to go and
they're not thinking about the
predictable future The Familiar past
they're dissociating from everything
physical and material everything
known that is the exact moment we call
getting Beyond yourself okay
now when we're in that place then at the
beginning it's uncomfortable because
we're survival is the unknown you better
chances of survival and running from the
unknown but that unknown is the perfect
place to create from so in the process
no different than any rehab in our first
two days of our event really people are
they're basically they're basically
rehabbing from their emotional states
and their habits and they're sitting in
the presence of that discomfort right
and the discomfort is because the body
is leaving the known but but but the
body has been conditioned to be the mind
the moment you take it outside of its
familiar territory it's going to start
telling you Ed why don't you quit you
know you're not really good at this you
know you're more of a physical person
you really want to do this you're not
very this or very that and most people
just get up when they do the meditation
they believe that thought as if it's
true now the question is what's on the
other side of that thought can you sit
there long enough till that's no longer
the thought you accept believe and
surrender to well then wow the next
question other side of that thought what
is the other what's on the other side of
that familiar emotion can I sit and work
with my body and settle it down
stay you stay I'm going to feed you
you're not going to die from this your
bladder's not going to explode you're
not going to go crazy and you work with
catching those thoughts it's called
metacognition if you're in that 95% of
programming where you're
unconscious then the first step to
change is becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts so conscious that
you would never go unconscious or let
that thought slip by you unnoticed I
want to understand so you're saying the
awareness of the thought being conscious
of the thought has it somehow lose its
power over you exactly exactly because
just because you have a thought doesn't
mean it's true and if you're left alone
to yourself you'll start believing every
thought you think yeah and that's the
problem so then the majority of people's
thoughts then are based on what they
perceive about themselves from their
past or their life right and if you
catch yourself complaining and blaming
and making excuses and judging someone
else and you say I want to be a happy
person well a happy person would never
do that would make them
unhappy if you notice that you've been
feeling guilty for the last 20 years you
didn't know it was guilt cuz it just
felt like you and you want to feel Joy
well if you can feel Joy it should tell
us
volumes about what you've been
practicing doing right so then most
people give up
because they they they don't know that
there's anything on the other side of it
so then the next question is what
thoughts do you want to fire and wire in
your brain well and with attention with
and with intention if you keep
practicing firing iring those thoughts
you start installing Hardware do it
enough times and it becomes like a
software program and now that's the new
voice you programm your head that said I
can do this I believe in myself and
you've created to an extent a new
personality which can create a new
personal reality now here we go so then
the next question is how am I going to
behave with my kids today how am I going
to be with my wife how am I going to be
with my partner how I going to be at
work how am I going to be on my zoom
calls how am I going to be by myself how
am I going to what what what does
greatness look like what does what would
love do today now it turns out that if
you close your eyes and you start
imagining doing that if you rehearse how
you're going to be in those certain
situations the evidence without a doubt
shows that your brain will start to look
like through the mental rehearsal of the
act that you've already done it now
you've installed the hardware keep doing
it it becomes a software program and
you'll start acting like a happy person
no magic there if you don't have the
circuits you can't do it so the
rehearsal then is actually changing the
brain just by thinking differently the
brain looks like the experience has
already happened now you have Hardware
to use do it enough times you get good
at it becomes more automatic now here's
the hard
part can I teach my body
emotionally what my future will feel
like before it happens now this is
really important because there's a
pandemic going on in the world that has
nothing to do with a virus it has
everything to do with people's attention
span and learning people need a rush of
dopamine in order to catch their
attention or a rush of adrenaline to
learn and so that they're they're
dependent on their outer environment to
regulate their emotional state now this
is different now now I'm going to say to
you get in that beautiful heart of yours
and I want you to feel gratitude for the
event before it occurs well I can't feel
it because it hasn't happened yet yeah
that's the conditioning that's the
hypnosis also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is practice meditation
we teach meditation three ways to become
familiar with your old self and to
become familiar with your new self
that's what the word meditation means
familiarization to become familiar with
so we use that model for change so slow
your brain waves down and get beyond
your analytical mind is meditation and
you teach your body how to do that and
we've discovered a formula that that
simply makes it very easy for people to
do it you practice it you'll get good at
it just like anything else practice so
so to get beyond the analytical mind
there's another way to reprogram
ourselves and then meditation is really
about getting beyond your body or
disconnecting from your body
disconnecting from your environment and
forgetting about time and that is that
eye of the needle where we begin to make
the most significant changes so we're
data driven you know we're really
looking to see what it is and and when
we see uh brains respond in the same way
it helps me enormously to teach the
material better and so the more people
understand what they're doing and the
more they understand why they're doing
it the more naturally the how becomes
easier and nothing is left to conjecture
if nothing is left to Superstition or
Dogma even in
spiritual you know traditional words you
science says the Contemporary language
to demystify that process you you give
new people numerous times to overcome
themselves and numerous times that
connect sooner or later you'll start
watching transformation right before
your eyes and so one of the cool things
that we've discovered is that we have so
much compelling data to suggest that
you're greater than you think more
powerful than you no more unlimited than
you could ever dream we have compelling
data that suggest that your nervous
system is the greatest pharmacist in the
world that it makes drugs that work
better than any drug in a drugstore drug
study is about 18 to 25% cause and
effect causality our data is between 75
and 85% cause and effect this is a
person creating their own Pharmacy of
anti-inflammatories their own Pharmacy
of anti-carcinogenic chemicals their own
Pharmacy of uh pain relievers who we're
seeing this over and over again so we
have this incredible data that says that
this is no longer pseudoscience this is
the real this is really science the
science effect of a person's
transformation is has changed my belief
in what's possible I have seen people
stand on the stage with stage four
cancers that were in every single organ
in their body that metastasize and and
they have no sign of cancer in their
body and we have data that suggests that
you put the blood of an advanced
meditator and an uterine cancer cell a
pancreatic cancer
cell 70% of the mitochondrial function
in the cancer cell is diminished the
mitochondria is the energy packets of
the cell it's taking energy out of the
cancer cell works perfect with what
we're seeing with uh uh the testimonials
uh that that people are telling around
the world we've seen blind people see
we've seen deaf people here we've seen
uh people with spinal cord injuries walk
again we've seen um ALS change we've
seen all kinds of unbelievable health
conditions change by a person simply
changing the way they think the way they
act and the way they feel rule number
five is set a Clear Vision if I was to
take off my coaching hat and put it on
you Dr Joe and you gave people one
assignment to take action on today what
would it be well I think it probably the
first thing I would have people do is to
really decide what they want in their
life I mean that's the first step decide
what what your future could look like
and and get clear on what that vision is
and write down the specific of what you
want in your life whether it's with your
family or your career or with a
relationship or whatever it is and and
get get clear on what that vision is of
yourself in the future and then write
down the
emotions of how you'll feel when it
happens will you be joyful will you be
enthusiastic will you be filled with
energy will you love your life and and
be in a state of grat a constant state
of gratitude and now you have a clear
intention and elevated emotion and every
morning morning when you start your day
before you open your eyes and reach for
your cell phone and check your WhatsApp
and your text and your Facebook and your
Twitter and your Instagram and your
LinkedIn and your emails before you plug
yourself back into your same familiar
World sit there and get very clear on
what that future will be like and begin
to emotionally embrace it before it
happens and if you do that properly
you're moving into a new state of being
and then at certain points in your day
just break and ask yourself how you're
doing how am I doing am I doing well am
I losing it am I falling from grace and
uh then recalibrate and and at the end
of your day ask yourself how you did and
and if you keep changing your state of
being over and over again your state of
being is your personality and your
personality creates your personal
reality and when you start seeing those
changes in your life and those
synchronicities the energy and the
excitement of the surprise of that event
is going to inspire you to create again
and I think that's how we move from
victims in our lives to creators of our
lives and rule number six the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
change your thinking if you think that
your thoughts have something to do with
your future just from a theoretical
standpoint that your thoughts Create
Your Destiny and you think 60 to 70,000
thoughts in one day and 90% of those
thoughts are the same thoughts as the
day before well then your life isn't
going to change very much as long as
you're thinking the same way and those
those same thoughts lead to the same
choices the same choices lead to the
same behaviors the same behaviors create
the exact same experiences and we
anticipate the same feelings or emotions
from those experiences and those
emotions are the payoff that drive our
very same thoughts while our biology our
neuros circuitry
neurochemistry our hormones and even our
gene expression will be equal to how we
think how we act and how we feel and how
we think how we act and how we feel is
called our personality and our
personality creates our personal reality
that's it so the present personality
who's listening to this show has created
the present personal reality called her
life so if you can latch on to this idea
if you want to create a new life a new
personal reality you got to change your
personality which means you better start
thinking about what you've been thinking
about and changing it you begin to
become conscious of your unconscious
actions or habits or behaviors and
modify them and then we have to begin to
look at the emotions that we live by
every single
day that'll keep us connected to the
past and decide do these emotions belong
in our future so most people are trying
to create a new personal reality as the
same personality and it doesn't work you
literally have to become someone else so
the principle of Neuroscience says that
nerve cells that fire together wire
together you keep thinking the same way
making the same choices demonstrating
the same habits creating the same
experiences that stamp the same networks
of neurons into the same patterns all
for the familiar feeling called you and
you do that for 10 years on end you're
going to begin to hardwire certain
patterns in your brain that becomes your
identity and by the time we're 35 years
old it kind of becomes fixed right then
psychology used to say that you can't
change that but we now know that you can
so then that kind of box in the brain
that is the habit of ourselves it's a uh
we're 95% of the time running a series
of programs so then sitting and doing
the work have we have to become
disentangled from those programs and so
the moment you decide to do something
differently or make a new Choice what
most people don't want to face is that
discomfort and that that discomfort that
that uncertainty that lack of
predictability the that that that
unknown is what people are afraid of cuz
they'd rather live in guilt at least can
predict who they're going to be then
take a chance and possibility so when a
person begins to understand this and you
say well how long have you been this way
and they say I've been like this for 35
years and you say why 35 years because
35 years ago I had this one event well
the stronger the emotion you feel from
the reaction from that event the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
the brain Narrows its focus and freezes
the image and takes a snapshot and
that's called a memory right so so then
forget the memory just overcome the
emotion cuz it's the emotion that keeps
you anchored to the past so that sounds
really good
theoretically but when you step out into
that unknown into that
void the body really is in a habit and
when a habit is when the body becomes
the mind or if you're thinking about
that past event and it's producing an
emotion well you need an image and a
feeling to start the conditioning
process so the body body is either
conditioned into the familiar past or
it's hardwired in the predictable future
cuz it wakes up every single day and
runs through the same series of routine
actions so the present moment then
becomes the unknown when people start
feeling that discomfort Jay they'd
rather get on their cell phone and call
someone or get up and say I can't
meditate or you know I I have too much
to do they excuse themselves they return
back into that familiar feeling because
the body's actually telling the brain
the happen is when the body becomes the
mind so the body stepping out into the
unknown and says ooh I'd rather feel
guilty I'd rather feel
unhappy than be in this discomfort so
then at least then when they return back
to that familiar feeling then they feel
safe so they step out in the unknown and
the body starts influencing the mind
saying you can start tomorrow you're too
busy it's your mother's fault you know
it's your culture's fault and I don't
have enough money this isn't going to
work those are the programs in there
that are standing in the way between you
and your future so then nerve cells that
no longer fire together no longer wire
together so the act of observing those
states of Mind and Body means you're no
longer the program you're the
Consciousness observing that program so
so then to meditate it means to become
familiar with so as you become familiar
with those thoughts you become conscious
of how you speak you become aware of how
you act you know notice how you're
feeling the more conscious you become of
those unconscious programs the less
unconscious you'll go in your waking day
why cuz it's not enough to just have a
great meditation and get up and get on
the freeway and get in traffic and
getting stressed you just return back to
the old self again our job then is to
sustain that modified State of Mind and
Body the entire day and if you can get
ready because something different or
unusual is going to begin to happen in
your life and it will come as a
coincidence or a synchronicity and
that's breadcrumbs from the Divine
saying you're on the path just keep
doing it there'll be another one just
keep staying in that energy and so
teaching people then to understand that
there's a formula that we now know that
if you apply that formula you'll begin
to see those changes and now as people
are doing it more and more uh
effectively the results are are going up
as well we just had Bond University they
just took a whole bunch of my brain
scans from 10 years ago huge clinical
study lot of analysis and and they're
Blown Away by the speed in which uh the
community can change brain heart
coherence they they know how to do it
it's not uh something that's that's
separate from them they've practiced it
enough times that they they now know how
to do it so what's the significance of
that well really simple in your
life if you start returning back to the
same reactions to the same people and
circumstances you're returning back to
the old self so you got to stay
conscious in your life and and if you're
not being defined by a vision of the
future then you're left with the
memories of the past and you will be
predictable in your life so Crossing
that River of change from the old self
to the new self there's a neurological a
biological a chemical a hormonal a
genetic death of the old self but if you
teach people there's something on the
other side they won't give up on
themselves they'll keep going so there's
enough evidence to encourage people and
you can't tell me you're too old to do
this work you can't tell me you're too
sick to do this work you can't tell me
you had a turbulent past or or that
you're too overweight or too underweight
or too out of shape or you can't even
tell me that you've never meditated
before in fact some of our greatest
scans are people who just have never
meditated before that are not trying to
do anything they just follow
instructions
so our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible and they
go all in not 50% in not 60% in if we do
a weeklong event we got 1,000 people or,
1500 people and they are all in and that
when they start getting Beyond
themselves that first day or second day
once they start getting Beyond
themselves and that magic starts to
happen then I have no idea I can't
predict
what's going to happen next and it's
usually pretty pretty
exciting broadening your awareness
starts to create brain coherence and
when the brain starts functioning in a
more orderly and coherent way and it
begins to synchronize and those
different compartments of the brain
start working together there comes a
moment where the two hemispheres of the
brain start to synchronize into balance
and the union of polarity the union of
opposites the union of Duality is called
wholeness and now we are creating from
wholeness instead of from lack or
separation and this is where it gets
exciting because when a person does this
properly and they can practice it our
research shows that people can change
their brain waves in 1 second in 4
seconds in 5 seconds in 12 seconds and
13 seconds and 19 seconds why because
they understand the process of getting
Beyond themselves so why is that
important for you because up until this
point whether you know it or not you
have be the process of practicing brain
coherence the first part of the formula
and
so when you open up your awareness in
your next meditation I'm going to ask
you as if you had no eyes no ears no
body to feel to smell to taste as if you
were just an awareness I'm going to ask
you to sense this Blackness and I'm
going to ask you to sense its depth I'm
going to say how far can your awareness
go into endless space and all I want you
to do is sense its infinite depth I'm
going to ask you to become aware that
there's infinite Blackness on both sides
of you and all I want you to do is
broaden your focus and to sense it to
feel it to stay connected to it and the
act of opening your awareness in sensing
space slows your brain waves down I'm
going to ask you to become aware that
there's Infinite Space behind you and
the act of sensing that Infinite Space
behind you causes your brain to start to
fire more orderly we've measured this
thousands of times and as if you were
just an awareness in that Blackness I'm
going to say to you now it's time to
become nobody no one no thing nowhere
and no time and take your attention off
of everything known into to invest it
into the unknown and like investing into
a bank account the longer you linger in
the unknown the more you create
possibilities in your life and if you
find your mind returning to your body to
your pain to your drives to your
emotions to your habits to thinking
about certain people or objects or
places or things in your known
predictable reality to thinking about
the familiar past or the eventual future
simply become aware that your attention
is on the known investing back into this
three-dimensional reality stop relax
return back to the present moment and
unfold back into possibility into the
Blackness you say that we have to master
the concept of the present moment what
does that mean well there's so much talk
about the present moment and being
present in the power of now but um most
people
um they spend the majority of their life
uh 95% of the time either living by some
past emotion or some past habit or
anticipating the future based on the
past and so we're very rarely in the
present moment and and paying attention
is being present and it's a skill just
like anything else the more you practice
it the better you get at it so think
about it feelings and emotions are the
end product of past experiences and you
can remember experiences better because
you can remember how they feel if you
wake up in the morning and you have to
search for The Familiar feeling called
you every morning and and that feeling
is unhappiness or frustration or lack or
insecurity or
fear the moment you get in touch with
that emotion you're starting your day
from the past because the emotion is a
record of the past now if that emotion
is connected to memories that are mapped
neurologically in your brain of certain
people at certain places at certain
times with certain things then the
moment you feel that emotion you
associate that emotion with the past
memory then you're activating circuits
in your brain from the past so of how
you think and how you feel creates your
state of being and thoughts of the
vocabulary of the brain and feelings are
the vocabulary of your body then your
entire state of being is in the past and
most people are living in the past so
their body is their unconscious mind and
it doesn't know the difference between
an experence exp erience in their life
that creates an emotion and an emotion
that they're creating by thought alone
to the body it's exactly the same so
those emotions start driving people's
thoughts and if they can't think greater
than how they feel and feelings have
become the means of thinking and they
believe that their thoughts have
something to do with their Destiny than
they're thinking in the past so they're
creating more of the same life and by
the same means if they wake up in the
morning and they come back to their
senses and they start out with the same
routine that they did yesterday and
they're going through a series of
routine habits of going to the toilet
making coffee eating breakfast taking a
shower driving the work the same way
then we could say for the most part a
person's future is nothing more than a
replication of the past and they're not
in the present moment and if they keep
doing that over and over again that
becomes a habit and a habit is a
redundant set of automatic unconscious
thoughts behaviors and emotions that's a
acquired through frequent repetition The
Habit is when you've done something so
many times the body has become the mind
so for most people their body is
dragging them into a predictable future
and they're on autopilot based on what
they've done in the past and they've
lost their free will to a program I
think anybody who is alive right
now who is engaged in
life has noticed a
quickening uh taking place in other
words every body feels like more things
are happening in a shorter amount of
time so there's an acceleration and time
is a construct in our mind there's no
circuitry there's no Hardware in our
brain to be able to understand time it's
a construct based on our past and how we
predict the
future
but
information is so readily available in
our world right now that in an age of
information ignorance is a
choice so you don't need an authority to
gain information any longer you don't
need a priest you don't need a governor
you don't need a doctor you don't need a
teacher you can access information at
your
fingertips so then as you begin to
discern the information with discernment
the proper and right
information you begin to develop some
type of empowerment because all of a
sudden you're seeing
possibilities that you never saw before
without that information so you wake up
you become more aware so the knowledge
creates awareness awareness creates
Consciousness Consciousness and energy
are connected so there's a change in
energy globally going on with the world
now that that that knowledge and that
change of energy has effects on
paradigms that are no longer a
vibrational match with that new level of
Consciousness so you see a political
systems unraveling you see economics
economic systems unraveling they're unsp
spiring they're unraveling they can't
sustain themselves with this new energy
you see
journalism the environment education
religion uh uh medicine it's all
unraveling because something greater has
to come as a result of a change in
Consciousness now no victims here
because when you and I negoti
iated from a soul level to be here at
this time this is the time we've been
waiting for this is this is where it's
happening in the Milky Way this is it's
happening here because there's a true um
Coming of a new Consciousness it's not
one person that's
coming it's a group it's a collective
Consciousness that's emerging and
emergence is uh one mind one heart and
the way you control people is you give
them misinformation based on emotions
you control people by controlling their
emotions and media and television and
advertisement is a great seduction that
people can watch a the news and get
really angry then change the channel and
watch a football game and get very
excited then change the channel and uh
watch a Sit calm and laugh and change
the channel and watch a drama and and
you can change your emotional state
because of
technology so then it means then most
people are relying
consciously or subconsciously on things
outside of them to make them feel a
certain way and so my interest is to
provide the proper content of
information scientifically to people so
that they reason that this is actually
possible then to give them the
opportunity to experience that
philosophy and get their behaviors to
match their intentions as many ways as I
can now if I do that properly people are
going to have new experiences
the experiences are going to change the
circuitry in their brain learning makes
connections but experience enriches
connections the end product of an
experience is an emotion so when you
start feeling worthy when you start
feeling a love for yourself when you
start feeling A Love For Life when you
start feeling truly grateful the moment
you feel that emotion you're teaching
your body to understand what your mind
is understood and living in stress is
when your response to the environment
causes you to activate the autonomic
nervous system and when you activate
that autonomic nervous system a branch
of it called the sympathetic nervous
system the figh ORF flight nervous
system is mobilizing all of the body's
energy all of the body's resources for
some danger in the outer environment are
you with me still and it mobilizes all
this energy to prepare the body to do
one of three things to fight to run or
to freeze and hide
and so the mobilization and tapping all
of the body's resources causes the heart
to race respiratory rate to increase
pupils to dilate digestive juices to
shut down blood sent to the extremities
the immune system dials up then dials
down we mobilize all this glucose to
have the energy to be able to run fight
or hide now in the short term that works
really well all organisms in nature can
tolerate short-term
stress
the human beings were a little bit more
complex sometimes it's not the Predator
that we're afraid of it's the person
sitting next to us at work sometimes
it's the news sometimes it's a reaction
to someone or
something and the constant knocking the
brain and body out of balance causes
that inbalance to become a new balance
and now the person is headed for some
type of breakdown some type of disease
because no organism can live in that
state emergency state for an extended
period of time let's just say that lack
is ingrained in there you got the story
you lived on the streets you lost
everything you got betrayed your
business partner took everything took
your wife took you got the story in the
half okay okay you got to start telling
a new story of the future right you got
to believe in that future more than you
have to believe in the past so how do
you do that you only believe in the past
when you feel the emotions of the past
the only time you're going to believe in
the future is when you feel the emotions
in the future right okay so in order for
us to change a belief or perception
about our s and our
lives we have to make a decision with
such firm
intention that the amplitude of that
decision carries a level of energy
that's greater than the hardwired
programs in your brain and the emotional
conditioning in your body and your body
literally has to respond to your mind
that the choice that you're making to
change in that moment becomes a moment
in time that you never forget and here's
the key physically physically the
stronger the emotion you feel when you
make that choice the more you remember
the decision okay so then how do we
downregulate that old belief if the
trauma created an emotional quotient of
six or seven then your decision to
change your beliefs got to be a nine
right and you got to come out of your
resting state and that moment has to
Define you you could say
I know exactly where I was the time of
day it was who I was with when I made my
mind up to change right cuz you created
a long-term memory long-term memories
are created from strong emotions right
but the amplitude of that emotion is
greater than the Betrayal Boom the body
starts responding to the mind and you're
actually giving your body a taste of the
future emotionally so you brand your
impossible no your body is actually
getting the taste of that future event
it's experiencing the future now now
exactly big explosion on the quantum
field big explosion so the side effect
of that is if you combine that clear
intention with that elevated emotion
you're basically remembering your future
and it looks no different than
remembering your past think
neurologically within the circuits of
that memory and feel within the emotions
of that new belief and watch your life
begin to change because nothing changes
in our life that we change and when we
change our energy we change our life so
now the experiment all of a sudden is no
longer based on it being hard or trying
or wishing or wanting or hoping that's
what we do when we're lacking we're in
lack of Separation it's about change so
then when we finally realize in order
for
us to become abundant we have to
overcome the old personality and that's
95% of who we are right yes so
then the side effect of the beginning of
this
process is a lot of dis discomfort it is
a lot of discomfort because you're
stepping outside the known into the
unknown and now you can't predict scary
no no you ra you'd rather hold on to
your lack the pain suffering rather tell
the story of that at least it makes you
feel something that's familiar when you
step outside and you're saying I'm not
going to complain about money any longer
I'm not going to complain about I don't
have any I'm not going to judge other
people who do I'm not going to say I can
I'm not worthy it's never going to work
all those things got to go I'm not going
to feel lack I'm not going to feel
unworthy I'm not going to feel
separation I'm not going to your
resentment these are the things that are
keeping my reality the same now it's no
longer about abundance about who you
become mhm so the overcoming process
becomes the becoming process and so many
people come through this work they want
abundance they want healing they want a
new relationship they want a new career
they want the mystical but really they
want wholeness and and they want healing
they want peace they want wholeness cuz
they feel unho well well when you're in
lack or you're in separation you're not
whole imagine feeling so much wholeness
that's impossible to want that's what
our that's what we're working on with
people then you can really enjoy a
sunset then you can really enjoy a meal
then you can really enjoy your friends
then you can I I I I talk to people that
are very abundant I mean in the billions
abundant and you know so many of them
say we are in misery our we're in agony
because they can't enjoy life anymore
that's what they want I mean people want
abundance to be able to enjoy life they
want to be able to do whatever they want
with whoever they want as many times as
they want wherever they want that's
Freedom right we want abundance the
sponsoring thought is really they want
freedom right or whatever their
sponsoring thought would be right I
think there are many modalities that
work for trauma what I've discovered is
that Insight never really changes
Behavior you can see that your father
was overbearing or was an alcoholic or
you could see all these different things
you know like you come up with the
Insight all these different things the
problem that I see with people is then
they tend to excuse their
change by saying oh I had a rough
childhood that's why I am the way I am
they're excusing their pre present
position so and again trauma is a
difficult thing but for
me the person who's living by the
identity in their life that they were
traumatized as a child or whatever it is
or they've had a trauma in their life
I'm not saying forget the trauma and
create another emotion I'm saying that
the person who's willing to go through
the
emotion and keep working on lowering the
volume to it the the we have had so many
people in this work with brutal pasts
really really difficult pasts do the
work and finally they reach that point
where they just break free from the emot
otion they look back and I have
interviewed enough of them it's the same
thing they look back at their entire
past and they don't want to change one
thing in their past cuz it brought them
to this elegant moment where they're
liberated they see their betrayers they
see their abusers they have nothing but
love for them now the side effect of
that and many times they'll say it was
like my heart blew wide open they had to
pass through the valley of the shadow of
Darkness to get there they just thought
I I don't know if I can go any further
and they went one more
time and the body literally was
liberated from the past right because
the trauma is not just in the brain the
trauma St emotionally in the body so you
want to take the body out of the past
out of the known what do you think the
body is going to say if it's been
conditioned to be the mind the unknown
is a scary place you step out into the
unknown you're going to be unprepared
for that trauma you don't know how it's
going to happen and so the person keeps
clinging to the known and but when the
person finally overcomes the emotion the
body literally is freed from the chains
of the past the side effect of that is
seeing the past from a greater level of
Consciousness lo and
behold there goes the Suicidal
Tendencies there goes the dysfunction
there goes the irritable bowel syndrome
that because the body was still living
in that past event by Liv by the same
emotion so the research on memory is
kind of fascinating and I just I've
studied it enough and and
and the way we recount the past is not
the way it happened even if you
absolutely think you remember it being
that way so we don't have the same brain
as we did when we were 8 years old or 12
years old or 20 years old we have a
different brain we have a completely
different brain so the fabrication of
the story for many people they embellish
the story and make it seem even worse
than what it was but you're really what
you're saying is I changed in those
moments and from a biological standpoint
I haven't been able to change since so
let me tell you why it's been so hard
for me to change and the story becomes
dramatized or
embellished the person Works them up
fire themselves into this emotional
froth and then fires and wires the same
circuits in the brain and they're
actually reaffirming their limitation
now there 's nothing wrong with that I
think we're just taking too long right
so 50% of that story isn't even the
truth it means in a sense we're we
living a miserable life that we never
even had and we don't want but but the
but the the unknown people would rather
cling to their
suffering this is not a judgment we all
do this we'd rather stay in the known
then take a chance in the unknown
because those emotions of survival are
saying what run from the unknown the
unknown is a scary place so now the
unknown you got to come up against that
moment where you're going to actually
leave that behind and step into the
unknown this is not a intellectual
process this is this is David and
Goliath there's a battle going on where
the body keeps wanting to go back to its
familiar State cuz it's subconsciously
been conditioned to be the Mind stay in
the known to overcome the
body takes a will that's greater than
the program to to no longer get up and
run through the same routine that you do
every day and your body wants in the
middle of meditation saying quit I'm too
tired you got too many texts you got too
many emails you got too many things to
do the body's been programmed to get up
and go and you and you say wait wait
wait wait wait a second here we're not
going anywhere until I get clear on who
I want to be today and every time you
execute that will that's greater than
the program people say oh I'm I can't
meditate actually you're doing it right
actually that's why it's hard because it
you're actually that is the process
right there there's no such thing as a
bad meditation what you're doing is
actually exactly what you need to do and
every time you do that you become
conscious that you go unconscious that's
how you actually develop the skill of
Consciousness it's not being conscious
it's catching yourself when you go
unconscious and people if they can see
thinking is the unconscious essentially
conscious is connecting to everything
which is in the space of nothingness
really but there's a journey to get
there and if you're patient with
yourself and you see that as a
victory like oh you start getting
aroused you start getting frustrated you
think I can't do this and you go oh no
no no no no no no we're not going to
quit here that would be me getting up as
the same person I'm curious what's on
the other side of this frustration you
settle your body back down into the
present moment you unfold back into that
Eternal space I'm telling you every time
you do that it's a victory you're
telling the body it's no longer the mind
that you're the mind and it actually
turns out that that the body starts
liberating energy it starts liberating
energy but like an unbridled stallion it
goes oh really you think that's all you
think that's all you have watch this and
then it get starts bringing up memories
of the past and all of that just to feel
an emotion and if you're aware that it's
doing that and you settle it down you're
you're taming the animal you're teaching
it you're you're teaching it how to
change its state right and guaranteed if
you keep doing that you walk out in your
life I guarantee you'll be less
responsive and reactionary to everyone
and everything so in seven days we see
that not only there dramatic biological
changes to suggest that the person
environment but it it goes for the
majority of people that immerse
themselves in going all in and what does
that mean a different environment
they're in a ballroom they're in a
ballroom I've been to thousands of
ballrooms there's nothing really
exciting in a ballroom what's exciting
in a ballroom they all look the same
same but the data suggests that they're
in a whole new environment where where
is that where is that taking place it's
taking place from within the person
closed eyed internal world is
everything open if you're living in
stress and you're living in survival and
that system is switched on then
everything will be a threat everything
will be a danger everything will be a
reason to rush to be impatient to be
frustrated to be judgmental because
that's that's the Consciousness that's
the emotion we're living by so now you
you have a a problem with a coworker you
have a problem with your partner
whatever it is that you use as an
example and you have to give a
presentation now now you really have one
of two choices either be
victimized by those conditions in your
life and you stay in that emotional
state and I'll say to you Jay why are
you that way well I'm this way because
of this person the circumstance the
person or circumstan is controlling the
way I feel and the way I think anything
that controls the way I feel and the way
I think I'm victim to right okay or I
actually can be a Creator now okay okay
so when it's the hardest it matters the
most okay so there's going to be a story
a valid story that's going to go along
with those emotions that you're going to
have to give up that you can address at
another time from a different state if
you're altered in that state and you say
something you do something you write the
email you send the text you'll always
regret it you'll always say I should
have never said that I should have never
done that we got to learn that we're in
an altered state at that time so there's
only one of two choices you either stay
there the whole day and tell everybody
that story or you say okay let me take a
moment remember that this is the
experiment called life okay let me
practice getting relaxed in my heart let
me slow the animal down let me practice
that take a few minutes now let me
breathe let me get my state back let me
change everything okay let me remember
who I am who I want to be when I open my
eyes and let me practice that again now
even if you had to do that 10 times in
one day I would say it was a day worth
living I I would say it was a day worth
living and when we do walking
meditations uh in our our Retreats we're
doing walking meditations so you can
practice doing it with your eyes open
like if you're going to be relaxed in
your heart and awake in your brain and
you can do it with your eyes closed okay
let's take it out for a test drive I me
open my eyes let me pay a little bit
more attention to my inner World let me
practice feeling this feeling let me
practice feeling this way and let me
brain do what it does let me get defined
let me change my physiology let me
change my state let me walk as the
healed person let me walk as the
Abundant person let me walk as if my
prayers are answered let me walk in the
state if I keep practicing that over and
over it's going to become a habit right
yeah so so we hit it as many ways as we
can we have at least seven or eight
different breaths that we do because we
see how they all work in the
brain we have all kinds of meditations
we have Sitting meditations we have
standing and walking meditations we're
laying down meditations because we want
you to be able to do it with your eyes
open with your eyes closed standing
walking any any way you can so that you
don't default and return back to that
person now if you do default you didn't
fail that's a program you just went
unconscious and how many times do we
have to forget until we stop forgetting
and start remembering that's the moment
of change no one no one cares how many
times you fell off the bicycle if you
ride the bicycle now you ride the bike
so it's it's the constant process uh
every single day and I think that
sometimes we look for evidence in our
life
and it hasn't happened and I think it's
so important that we still show up yeah
yeah cuz that's the that's where you're
changing the most and when you get to
that point where you could care less if
it happens or not because you feel so
happy so grateful for who you are get
ready because your life is going to
begin to change in magical ways most of
us tell the story of our past in a
negative Sense on how it's held us back
um millions of times over our life as
opposed to the story of the future of
what we want to create or who we want to
become yeah listen again you tell that
story in the latest research on memory
says that memory is creative that in
fact 50% of that story you embellish
people make up that story let me tell
you why they make up that story because
they excuse themselves for the fact that
they haven't been able to change since
that event they'll have to make it sound
worse than it really was to make it
harder to grow and change so that they
can reaffirm their limited sense of
their inability to change so then that
story becomes more and more of a story
and it's less of the truth because you
got to work yourself up into a state
there were lions and tigers and there
was right you know there were
helicopters snowstorms yeah everybody
was firing bullets worse thing you could
possibly IM and then you got to feel
that emotion right and then you look oh
yeah it must have been really bad now
that's that's your identity now that's
your identity and the more you hold on
to that identity of the past the harder
it is to become who you want to be in
the future well here's here's to answer
the other part of your question when we
started talking how do you get that
person out of their past yeah well you
got we need a week it's not gonna happen
it doesn't happen overnight no I want
them to come right up against their fear
I want them to come right up against
their doubt I want them to come up
against the point where they're going to
give up and quit and they're going to
sit there and nobody else is giving up
and quitting and they're going to go all
in more and they're going to start
believing what there's something on the
other side of that emotion they're going
to believe that there's something past
the story of their past because they're
stretching themselves out of the known
and it takes a tremendous amount of
awareness repetition information model
building sharing understanding
experiencing to finally have a person
get to the point where they just let go
and when they do the body's liberated
from the past and there's a release of
energy and we now know that there's a
formula to teach people how to do that
in fact we're getting so good at it that
the first two days day and a half
sometimes one day in certain groups of a
week-long event is about retiring that
past finishing it you know this is when
the story ends this is when they get
over it now the next five
days the person's ready to create a new
future and they're not going to have a
problem teaching their body what it
feels like to be in love with life to
feel like all their needs are met that
they're free they are going to fall in
love with it and they are going to begin
to Signal new genes they're going to
begin to change to brain circuitry their
brain chemistry their immune system
their gene expression the tell it's all
going to happen they're they're more of
that future self and and they're they're
headed to a future now here's the deal
though you got to be able to sustain
that state when you return back to your
life that's the name of the game you got
to be able you got to bring the game
into your life now and no person no
circumstance no condition in your life
would cause you to feel the old way
again because the moment you started
feeling victimized the moment you
started feeling angry you just return to
the old self you disconnected from the
energy of your future and you're back to
the energy of your
past because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
for four incredible hours of Joe
despenza motivation check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there everybody Dr Joe here little
tip for you to change is to be greater
than your environment that means to be
greater than the conditions in your life
to be greater than the circumstances in
your world and every great person in
history knew this